("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
So let's expand on
shooting for the moon
and landing on the clouds
or shooting for the
clouds and landing on the roof.
Shoot for the fucking moon
because the stars are better
than if you shot for the clouds.
'Cause if you shoot for
the clouds you're gonna
end up on the roof.
Here comes Jordan.
Jordan's running.
Running for our workout.
There he is.
There we go, there we go.
Anyway, hey.
- Hey.
- Alright, so anyway, what I
meant in there was the fact of
the matter is that people's
goals aren't big enough.
Like I think that people make
way too many short-term goals
and they're thinking in one or
three year macros and so for me
one of the great things about
trying to buy the New York Jets
is it's stretching my thinking.
A lot of my
behavior is five, seven,
12, 15 years long and so
I think that when
your goal is to you
know own a BMW or if your goal
is to get a Rolex watch your
behavior becomes
more short-term.
So one of things
I try to teach my managers,
my entrepreneurs, my audience
is level up your thinking.
Try to leave a legacy.
All of a sudden you
become a better person.
Try to buy the New York Jets all
of a sudden you become a more
successful business person.
Stretch your goals.
Make me a promise after this
episode stretch your goals.
One of the things to
expand in this weekly recap is
why did I buy PureWow.
You saw a lot of
PureWow meetings this week.
Obviously, VaynerMedia
is an agency, right?
A paid media agency, we buy ads
on websites and other platforms.
A creative agency, we make
pictures and videos that you see
on those platforms but part of
my plan always along with
VaynerMedia was to create and
or buy a media company.
Sports Illustrated, ESPN,
Cande Nest and Hearst,
People magazine but what does
that look like in a digital age?
The age of Vice,
the age of Refinery 29,
the age of Barstool and
so looked for about a year.
Wanted to create a holding
company, Vayner X, that the
VaynerMedia stuff would sit over
here and the Gallery is what
I call the media world,
PureWow being the
first acquistion in that world.
PureWow to me was winning
in that upper Millennial,
low Gen X female demo which
makes the buying decisions of
most products in our homes today
and was a very attractive place.
Plus Mary Kate
the editor, that voice,
her team, incredible.
Ryan Harwood, a
friend friend off the field.
Watched him from afar, never
even considered PureWow 'cause
Ryan was a friend off the field
and then stumbled into it about
18 months ago, 15 months
ago as a conversation.
Got to the right price on both
ends and made the move and now
the goal is really to create
one of the great female media
brands of all time around
PureWow so I'm excited about it
so just to round
out the repertoire.
You kinda have a, you
know you have a Army belt,
a Batman belt of
different things.
And so PureWow and media
companies and I'll be looking to
get more but PureWow
was really at huge scale,
one of the top five, seven
players in that female demo but
was really built
around the creative,
the story not traffic arbitrage
from Facebook or Instagram or
things of that nature.
Plus, it felt like there was a
lot of what I was learning on
Instagram and Facebook that
could be applied to PureWow.
So one plus one
equals three scenario.
And just the progression.
The progression of the
journey, of the master plan.
It was the right time.
VaynerMedia's at scale,
time to build out the media
property arm of this journey.
- Hey Gary. I'm
having a question.
You are building a personal
brand next to your companies and
I would like to know
whether everybody should
have a personal brand.
So businesses come and go
the person stays longer usually.
Let's say 80 years so it
might be a very good idea
to have a personal brand.
So let us know please.
Thank you and
greetings from Germany.
- Q Health, listen I wrote a
book in 2009 called "Crush It!"
about building personal brand.
I'm writing a book right now
either titled
"Crushing It!" or "Crushed It!"
As a matter of fact,
this is a good opportunity.
Leave in the
comments what do you think,
should I call it "Crushing It!"
or should I call
it "Crushed It!"?
It's a story about the
people that read "Crush It!"
are winning and an updated
version of how to build a
personal brand in
today's environment.
Q Health, as far as building a
personal brand alongside your
business, I'm doing it.
I'm a fan of it but I also
think I have the personality,
the skills, the stomach and
appetite for all the people that
want to know troll
and things of that nature.
I think it's a
very personal thing.
I think it's
like raising a family.
It's like a relationship.
I don't want to fly in here
and tell you everybody should.
Everybody who's capable and
wants to should jump into the
pool if you're debating it
'cause there's a
lot of vanity there.
I do think in 2017 some of the
narcissistic kind of vanities
have gone away as all of us are
now kinda putting out content
and living some version of a
personal brand in comparision to
2008 when I wrote "Crush It!"
and 2009 when it
came out so you know,
yes, I'm a fan of it and I think
there's a lot of upside that
comes with it but like anything
in life there's a
ying and yang, right?
So there is definitely
some baggage and some personal
feelings getting
hurt and you got to have
the stomach for that feedback.
So, I'm a fan.
I think people should do it.
I think it's good for business.
I do think that as your business
career evolves it means that you
have a base every time you start
something new if you decide to
go that route and so
I'm passionate about it.
I think it's good.
Okay, what did I mean by
("Small Conversations
at Parties" By Derek Pope)
You see where I'm going?
We're fixing the
airplane while we fly it.
By the way, by not
taking a stop in
Providence, Rhode Island to
fix something and then
Kansas City, Missouri we've
lapped the world 15 times while
everybody's still fixing their
brakes in fucking Wichita.
The big thing there
is that too many people,
oops, too many
people aren't moving.
You always have to
be constantly moving.
It's like right now, just
got done with these hard rows,
I felt like I had it in my mind,
even though I'm not breathing
super well, I'm just moving.
I'm just gonna work through it.
I'm not gonna wait.
Too many people think
that you have to stop,
fix and go.
I think very much
like it's NASCAR, right?
You come in pit, move.
I've had a lot of problems at
VaynerMedia but I don't stay off
the offense on a lot of the
great things that are going on.
VaynerTalent, Vayner
the small business thing.
By the way, small
businesses hit me up.
You know, the consulting stuff,
the video production stuff,
the paid media stuff.
Sure, there's a lot of things to
fix but too many people dwell on
what's wrong with their
organization and they spend all
their mind time, their
strategy on trying to fix that.
That's like parking
the plane and fixing.
I'm like look, I got to fix
those things 'cause if you don't
fix it, the company breaks.
But I'm gonna
stay on the offense.
I'm gonna keep flying my plane
and fixing it midstream and so
that's what I mean by that.
You don't have to dwell, stop
and address all your issues and
then when it's
perfect you move forward.
It's a huge mistake
that slows you down.
That's why so many
people build smaller businesses.
One of the reasons I've built
very big businesses is that of
course I've got to fix them
because if you don't fix them
you die but I'm always tripling
down on my offense as well.
fixing the plane
while you're flying it.